So, we continue the French Revolution
today. And last class, we looked at a
Jean-Jacques Rousseau.
And how he is the philosopher poet of
the revolution. He provided the dream,
okay?
For the revolution. He told the French
that there was a promised land
of reason, where
if you use your reason, which is God's
gift to us,
you could build a new society. A utopia,
kingdom a kingdom on Earth.
And today's class, we will look at
Robespierre, Maximilien Robespierre, who
is a prophet who will take his people
into the promised land.
All right, so he is the main instigator,
the main leader of the French
Revolution.
And
I'm going to make a very strange
argument today about Robespierre that no
one has made before. So, it's going to
be very controversial, it's going to be
very strange. So,
I will do this very slowly, okay?
Basically,
I'm going to make the argument to you
that Robespierre
saw himself as the second coming of
Jesus.
And because he did so,
he sacrificed himself in order to save
the French Revolution, okay? So, that's
my argument to you today.
Again, it's going to be a very
controversial, provocative argument, so
I will work very slowly to explain it.
All right. Okay. So, let's go over some
um
Let's review some information we
discussed last class. That's very
important. Okay. So,
as we discussed last class,
traditionally in Europe, there have been
two major groups of people, okay? There
there are the peasants
and the poor.
And the slaves, okay? So, basically, the
lower class, the underclass.
And then at the top are the nobility
and clergy.
Now, there's always been towns people.
There's always been merchants and
artisans and crafts people, but they're
the minority.
But because of the gunpowder revolution
as Europe begins to industrialize
um these people are growing in number
and in influence and in power, okay? And
we call these people today the middle
class.
And the middle class is an extremely
diverse
uh group of people.
And you can
simplify the middle class into three
major categories, okay? There's the
bourgeoisie.
The bourgeoisie, remember are the elite
of the town. So, these are
bankers, lawyers, doctors
factory owners
um industrialists merchants, okay? So,
they are the elite of
a town.
Then you have
what we what we call later the
proletariat.
Okay? The proletariat um are the lower
class of a town. They include artisans
uh workers
Okay?
They're often the majority.
And then in between are what we call the
petite bourgeoisie
or the petty middle class.
And these are just people who are just
stuck in between these two major
categories. And they include um
school teachers
journalists
um small lawyers
okay? Notaries
Small business owners. Okay, so this is
extremely diverse group of people. Okay?
Now, and as we discussed last class,
what often happens in revolution is that
is that
the petty bourgeoisie will often be the
become the counter elites.
The counter elites are just those who
lead the people to revolt against the
elites.
The proletariat will be the muscle or
the army.
Okay?
And the bourgeoisie are in a very
unstable position because at first they
they will often support revolutions
because they want more political power.
But over time, they will
uh become reactionaries.
Or they will try to
control the revolution or even kill the
revolution because the revolution is
threatening threatening their economic
interests. Okay? So, this is the pattern
that we see in human history. Okay.
So, um let's let's go over some terms
that we will need in order to understand
the French Revolution. Okay. Um
So, what happens is this.
The middle class is growing in France
throughout the 17th and 18th century. In
fact, they become the main economic
engine
for France. At this time, France is the
most populous, the wealthiest nation in
all of Europe. But, it is an absolute
monarchy. An absolute monarchy is one in
which the king makes all the decisions.
He decides whether or not to go to war.
He decides who has the power. He decides
who has to pay taxes, okay? He has
absolute power in absolute monarchy.
The absolute monarchy
leads France into a series of disastrous
wars
in this in the 18th century.
The most prominent, the most important
is something called the Seven Years'
War.
Fought between France and England
primarily. There were other participants
as well.
And this is a world war, okay? This is
really the first world war. You You can
You can actually call this World War
Zero. It's fought all all around the
world, in North America, in Europe, um
in Asia. It's fought everywhere. And
France loses this war.
Okay, when you lose the war, you incur a
lot of debt. But not only that,
right after Seven Years' War, France
sponsors the American Revolution.
Okay? So, France becomes the main
uh
uh economic, political, and military
sponsor of the Americans in the
revolution against the British. And of
course, the Americans win this war.
But the Americans refuse to pay back the
debt that they owe to the French.
Okay? So, these are two major wars
that are now that have now left um
France in very dire economic straits. In
fact, their treasury is empty.
Okay?
The government has no more money.
Food prices are
um
off the charts. People
don't have enough to eat. There's no
bread. The economy's in tatters.
Okay? So, what the king needs to do now
is he needs to call
an assembly of the people, okay? And
this And this what's called the Estate
General. The Estate General.
And this happens in the year
1789.
And this marks the beginning of the
French Revolution.
And the purpose of this Estate General,
it's very simple.
All the king wants to do is get these
people, the nobility, the clergy, and
the middle class, the bourgeoisie, to
agree
to give him more money, okay, to pay
more taxes, to replenish the treasury.
Of course,
the middle class,
everyone in the middle class is like,
this is a bad deal for us.
We are the main economic engine for
France. We pay the most taxes. We do the
most work, but we have no political
power.
Therefore, we should have some political
power. In fact, we should check the
power of the king to
uh declare war and to raise taxes, okay?
So, they want a constitutional monarchy.
No, at this time in history, no one is
saying that they should depose the king
and declare republic. No one is saying
that, okay? All they want is a more
um the a greater diffusion of power.
All right, less power for the king, more
power for the people.
That makes sense.
Okay? But, of course, the king
and the elite don't really like this
idea.
And the king
um this is Louis the 16th, and he's very
indecisive in
decisive, okay? He wants to maintain the
absolute monarchy, but he lacks the
cutthroat mentality mentality that that
he would need to uh
achieve
um his power, okay? So,
he should have sent in the military to
kill everyone, but he didn't want to do
that. He goes back and forth, okay? And
so, what happens is now
the Estates General breaks off.
In the Estates General, there are three
estates, Three major groups. There's the
you know, the first estate is called the
clergy, the Catholic Church. The second
estate is the nobility. The third estate
is everyone else, the commoners, okay?
So, what happens is the third estate
breaks off and they form something
called the National Assembly.
And they use the National Assembly as a
mechanism
to press
for more rights.
And the National Assembly, because it's
made up of most of the members of the
middle class, you have different groups
of the proletariat, the petite
bourgeoisie, the bourgeoisie.
Um they argue amongst themselves as
well.
So, what what's happening now is that
within the National Assembly
these political groups, political clubs
are forming
in order to devise strategy and to
consolidate um ideology amongst
themselves, okay? And the most famous of
these clubs is are called the
Do you guys remember? The Jacobins.
Right? And have you guys studied this
history?
Okay, the Jacobins. Oh, anyway, the
Jacobins.
The Jacobins club.
And this is just a meeting place for um
revolutionaries to come together and
discuss ideology. How do we best
proceed? Now, over time as the
revolution develops
the Jacobins will split off into other
groups, okay?
Um
and the the reason why they split off is
because the economic interests, the
political, economic, social interests of
these different groups do not align with
each other.
All right? So, from the Jacobins you
will emerge the Feuillants.
The Feuillants represent the
bourgeoisie.
They don't want any economic change,
they want political change.
They don't want to um have a more equal
society, they just want more power over
the king, okay? So, these are
conservatives.
But then you will also emerge the
Girondins. Girondins. Now, Girondins are
lower bourgeoisie. These are merchants.
These are tradespeople. And what they
want is war.
They want French to declare war against
their enemies, Austria, Prussia,
basically. And the reason why is if
there's war, they can make money off
war.
Okay? Because these are merchants, these
are tradespeople.
Um these are industrialists. So, they
see war as an opportunity to enrich
themselves. They're speculators,
basically. And these are called the
Girondins.
And then you will also emerge the
Cordeliers.
And the Cordeliers represent a more
extreme faction of the Jacobins who want
universal suffrage.
They want the proletariat to have more
rights. Okay. Um
at this point the proletariat
is called the sans-culottes.
The sans-culottes. Okay? These are very
important people because they provide
the muscle
for the revolution. Sans-culottes is
French meaning without breeches. So, the
custom at that time is that if you are a
middle-class person, you wear like silk
socks, okay?
But, they're expensive. So,
uh the middle the lower class of
proletariat, they they don't they cannot
afford these socks. Therefore, they're
called the sans-culottes, okay? The
sans-culottes.
And the Cordeliers want to galvanize
these people to create a full revolution
where the complete social, economic,
political, and religious order is
overthrown, okay?
Then you have people called the
Hébertists.
And what they want to do is overthrow
the Catholic Church.
Okay? So, throughout this revolution,
over time, you have different groups
emerging with different political
interests within the middle class.
Okay, does that make sense?
But, at the same time,
you have threats to the revolution.
Okay? So, the main threat is the king
because the king, he's a Bourbon,
and his brother his brother is king of
Spain. He has relatives all over Europe.
So, he writes to Austria, Prussia to ask
for aid. Can you come in, send your
army, and crush this revolution for me
because my army is not listening to me,
okay? So, the king is conspiring against
the revolution. There are these
invasions from Austria
and Prussia, okay?
And then England
also sees the revolution as a threat as
well.
Because remember, every nation has a
middle class, and they're afraid that
the middle class in their nations will
rise up against them as well.
So, you have these external threats
coming in. And then you also have
internal threats, okay? You have
counter-revolutionaries, the nobility
who try to raise their own armies to
crush the revolution. You also have
economic collapse
going on, okay? So, so the revolution at
this point, in the year 1990, 1991, it
seems threatened.
So, what happens is that someone emerges
from this chaos to lead the revolution,
and his name is Maximilien Robespierre.
Okay? Maximilien Robespierre.
And Robespierre, he is just a provincial
lawyer, okay? He is not from Paris, he
is from Arras,
um a province in France. He's a lawyer,
and he's part of the petite bourgeoisie.
And he's not imposing, he's not huge.
He's He's not He's not powerful. He
doesn't have a faction behind him.
And he's not extremely charismatic. He
He He He's almost like a nerd.
But the thing about Robespierre is that
he is completely convinced
that the revolution
must win and it will win if he works
hard enough. He works 18 hours a day.
The moment he gets up, he works. He
gives speeches. He He gives over 500
speeches in the National Assembly over
his career.
Um
he is extremely virtuous.
He's He He comes to Paris with no money
and he leaves Paris with with no money.
His entire career as a lawyer back at
his hometown he spent defending the poor
and the weak against the powerful.
And he has very clear ideas about how to
to proceed with the revolution based on
Jean-Jacques Rousseau, okay? He sees
himself as a disciple of Jean-Jacques
Rousseau. Okay, remember last class we
looked at Rousseau's ideas
and and how to implement um a kingdom of
reason. Okay?
So,
um
Robespierre, because he is the most
virtuous, he is the most um
he has the most conviction, he becomes
the de facto leader
of the revolution.
Okay?
Uh he becomes head of something called
the Committee
for Public Safety.
And it's not a dictat- it's not a
dictatorship, okay? He's not a dictator.
But he's head of a commu- committee that
advises National Assembly on how to
proceed. And because he he is the most
forceful, he has the most ideas, his
ideas usually win out.
Okay?
And what And
over time, as he accumulates more and
more power, he makes more and more
radical proposals.
His most radical
proposal is called the Reign of Terror.
The Reign of Terror is a time of mass
mass
execution, okay, the guillotine
in Paris.
To in order to solidify the revolution,
in order to advance the revolution,
Robespierre says, "We must instill
terror
in our enemies.
We must investigate our enemies and
execute them if they are plotting with
the king against us.
If they are plotting with enemies
against us, if they are conspiring
against us, if they are engaged in
economic speculation, if they are
hoarding food, these are all enemies.
They're trying to sabotage the
revolution, therefore we must
kill them." Okay? So, over a few years,
three or four years, the Reign of Terror
will kill
at least 40,000 people within Paris
alone, okay? We don't know in the
provinces
uh how many how many how many people are
killed.
The Reign of Terror will also execute
the king and queen.
So, they will kill the king and queen as
well.
All right?
So,
historians have been debating for a long
time if the Reign of Terror
uh was necessary because ob- obviously
it's a terrible thing to kill tens of
thousands of people for holding
opposing political opinions, okay? And a
lot of these people were in fact just
political enemies of Robespierre.
Okay? So, how can we best understand the
Reign of Terror? Well,
if you think about it, in this class, we
we've actually studied the Reign of
Terror before, okay? It's the idea of
human sacrifice.
And we have discussed this before. Uh
all societies engage in war
pre-modern times practice human
sacrifice. The Romans did it, the the
Vikings did it, the Aztecs did it, okay?
The Aztecs were famous for for doing it.
So, why would you
do human sacrifice if you're engaged in
war? Okay? Well, there are different
reasons.
And there are three main reasons. The
first reason is you want to unify and
energize the people.
Okay? When people
observe or they watch
human sacrifice, when they when they
engage in a spectacle, they become much
more excited. They be They have
bloodlust, okay? We call that bloodlust.
Warlust.
They want to kill now, okay? They get
They're excited to kill.
Okay? That's one purpose.
Second purpose, of course, is to
terrorize
your enemy. To put fear in your enemy,
okay? That's obvious. And then there's a
third reason, which is the most
important.
The third reason is to break taboo.
Okay? To break ta- ta- the taboo.
When you break a taboo, you are
signaling that you are crossing a
boundary.
You've crossed a line, and you can never
go back.
You can no longer compromise. You can
only move forward.
Okay? So, the taboo they broke in the
French Revolution is they killed the
king and queen of France.
That meant that now all of Europe would
unite against the French, and they would
come and exact a bloody vengeance on the
people of France.
The enemies of France, which include
England,
the Netherlands,
Prussia, Austria, Russia, the five most
powerful nations in all of Europe.
They would They They will now come and
they will not stop until they have
avenged
the the the dead king and queen, okay?
They've because the French people have
broken this taboo and the monarchs
cannot allow
the French people to get to to get away
with this, okay? Because if they did,
then this would encourage their people
to rise up against them as well.
Okay? So, by with the Reign of Terror,
Robespierre
breaks the taboo.
And when you break the taboo, then you
are now all in. You are fully committed
to the revolution.
There's no more compromise. There's no
more surrender. There's no more
uh going back into the past. You are now
in the promised land. You are now in a
new world. You must fight to the death
for this world.
Okay?
Does that make sense?
Okay.
But, what happens
next,
um and it's very strange is Robespierre
has accumulated all the power in France.
He's not dictator. He doesn't have the
power to be dictator, but he's de facto
dictator. And at this point in his life,
he's only like in his mid-30s, he could
choose to become king, right?
He could be like, you know what? For the
revolution to fully succeed, I need to
become the dictator. And the people, the
sans-culottes,
love him.
The Jacobins love him.
He would win.
Okay?
But, at this particular stage in the
revolution,
he decides
to just sit at home. He goes into
seclusion. He kind of gives up.
And this allowed This gives time for his
enemies to conspire against him. And he
has a lot of enemies because this is
this is the Reign of terror. Robespierre
is virtuous.
And no one can be as virtuous as
Robespierre. And his enemies think this
guy is crazy. He's going to kill
everyone
who is not as virtuous as
he is. And therefore, we're all going to
be killed at some point, okay? So, they
try to they decide to act first. So, the
National Assembly conspire to vote for
his kind of catenation.
They vote for his death.
And he does not resist. The most he does
is he goes to the National Assembly and
he gives a speech cursing them all.
Okay?
And then but then afterwards, they send
uh soldiers to arrest him and he doesn't
really resist. And then he's sent off to
the guillotine and then he's killed. And
that's the end of Robespierre.
And this is a mystery, a paradox, to
historians like
why did Robespierre fall? Why didn't he
resist?
Why did he just give up? Okay?
All right. So, to answer this question,
I'm going to provide you with a
new idea.
Okay?
And this is a hard idea, so please feel
free to challenge me or ask questions.
Make sure you're clear, okay? All right.
So, the thing you you need you need to
understand is this.
In a time of revolution, when people
reject authority,
when people say, "I no longer believe in
God. I refuse to listen to my priest.
The nobility is evil. I refuse to submit
to the king."
The question then is, what takes charge?
What guides society now?
And the answer is
mythologies.
Mythologies are the subconscious
operating system
of society. Okay, does that make sense?
So, what mythology does everyone in
France know? Well, the story of Jesus,
right? What's the story of Jesus?
Um
Jesus
is persecuted
for telling the truth, for trying to
bring about a more equal, more just
world.
In fact, he is murdered. He's crucified,
okay? He's cru- cru-
crucification, okay?
And the moment he's crucified, people
discover that he's truly the son of God.
And then, after he dies, he ascends to
heaven,
where he wait he awaits the day when he
has to return, okay? And he does return
in something called the Second Coming.
Second Coming.
And
the Second Coming, Jesus will become the
god of war, okay? The Messiah.
And he will lead his people into victory
against the entire world.
And once he defeats the entire world, he
will build a kingdom of heaven, a
thousand years of peace.
And then, after the thousand years of
peace,
heaven will come onto Earth, we will all
become immortal, and those who have been
good will live in heaven, those who have
been bad will burn in hell, okay? The
final judgment. Okay, so that's a story,
a mythology, that everyone understands,
that everyone knows in France.
And so, even though the French
Revolution was a revolution of reason,
when they're trying to reject the
Christian faith, the mythology is still
implanted in their brains. And this
mythology becomes the operating system
of the French Revolution.
Okay?
So,
um using this mythology,
let's now ask ourselves,
what happened
when Robespierre died? Okay? Three
things happened when Robespierre died.
The first thing that happened is
Robespierre became a scapegoat.
Okay? A scapegoat is someone who takes
the blame for all the crimes of the
community.
So, the Reign of Terror is when the
Parisians killed 40,000 people, and some
of them were innocent.
And when Robespierre died, he took the
blame for the Reign of Terror, right?
They killed him because they called him
a tyrant. He's the one responsible for
those 40,000 deaths.
And he said, "Sure, I'll take the
blame." Okay? He could becomes a
scapegoat. That's the first thing that
happens. Second thing that happens is he
becomes a martyr
for the revolution. He died in order to
save the revolution.
Robespierre said to the people, "If you
need me to die in order to cleanse you
of your sins, then I will do so. I will
do so because what matters is not my
life, but the revolution."
Okay? He becomes a martyr.
And when he become a martyr, what he did
was he made people feel guilty for
having persecuted and killed him, okay?
And so, the third thing he becomes is a
role model
or a
paragon,
a hero.
He's telling the French people, "Listen,
I could have become king. I had all the
power in the world, but I chose to
sacrifice myself because what mattered
most was the revolution.
If you feel guilty for having killed me,
then you have an obligation to the
revolution to sac- to make the sacrifice
necessary in order to save the
revolution, okay?
So, this is what happened. The moment he
killed himself, he became a scapegoat, a
martyr, and a paragon of virtue, a hero
to the people.
People will feel guilty for having
killed him, and now that they will
transfer this guilt into promoting and
saving the revolution.
And so,
in other words,
uh the moment that he died, G-
Robespierre became Jesus.
He became in the minds of the French
people
second coming of Jesus.
Does that make sense?
Okay? So, that's my argument to you
today.
And so, over the the rest of the class,
we will look at the evidence. And
actually, the best evidence is
how Robespierre died.
Okay?
So, let's compare the death of Jesus and
the death of Robespierre, and you will
see they match up.
They line up perfectly, okay?
So,
let's look at the death of
Jesus.
And then we'll look at Robespierre, his
death.
Jesus
spends his life
preaching the truth to the people and
trying to build a more just and equal
world.
But he knows that eventually he must die
in order to complete his mission, okay?
So, at the in the Last Supper,
he tells his followers,
the disciples, "One of you will betray
me." Okay, betrayal. And of course, this
person's name is Judas Iscariot, who
betrays Jesus to the high priest of
Jerusalem, okay?
So, the So, the first thing is betrayal.
But, after the dinner,
everyone goes to sleep, and Jesus goes
to a quiet place, okay? He isolates
himself.
Why? Because he knows
that
the soldiers are coming to arrest him
and to put him to death, okay? The
servants of the high priest are going to
come and arrest him.
The servants do come to arrest Jesus,
and Jesus submits, okay? Submission. He
does not resist.
But, one of his disciples, Peter, he he
sees what's happening, and he rushes to
try to save Jesus.
And Peter cuts off the ear of one of the
servants of the high priest. And Jesus
tells him, "No. No, no, Peter. Go home.
This is what I must do by myself. I must
go with the with the high to the high
priest, okay? He goes to the high
priest, who then presents him to the
Roman governor, Pontius Pilate, right?
And Pontius Pilate says, "Jesus, you've
been accused of crimes against your
people,
of defying the laws of your God.
What do you have to say in your
defense?" And Jesus says, "Nothing."
Jesus does not defense defend himself,
okay?
Okay? So, submission, okay?
And then Pontius Pilate says, "Fine. If
you refuse to defend yourself, then I
can only condemn you to death."
So, Jesus um there's he has to bear a
cross, okay? And he's bearing the cross,
the Jews line up and see him, and they
jeer him, okay? They curse him. They
spit at him. They throw stones at him.
And all this while, there's someone, a
soldier, a centurion, following him and
whipping him, okay? This is called the
passion.
Okay? He is punished.
And then he is of course crucified. And
he's crucified, it's the worst way to
die, right?
People, thousands of people
come and watch him be get crucified and
then die.
Okay? That's the story of Jesus.
Guess what, guys?
This story
becomes
the death of Robespierre, too.
So, Robespierre is
betrayed.
He's betrayed by his political allies
and friends.
He helped these people amass power.
And once they amass power
and Robespierre gets rid of all the the
other enemies,
they see Robespierre as the ultimate
threat. So, they conspire against him,
okay? So, it's a betrayal.
Robespierre is asked to speak to the to
the assembly, he does, okay? But, he
knows the assembly has already condemned
him to to death. There's no point in him
arguing, okay? So, what he does is after
his speech, he goes to a building, a
town hall, and he goes to the second
floor, and he and he is isolated from
everyone, okay? He knows his fate. He
knows they're going to come and kill
him, and he just stands there.
His friends, his most loyal followers,
okay?
Say to him, "Robespierre,
they're coming to kill you. Let's rally
the people. Let's go to the sections,
the sans-culottes. We have thousands,
tens of thousands of loyal followers.
Let's rally them. Let's inspire them to
revolt. Let's
Let's raise an army and kill the entire
National Assembly." And Robespierre
refuses, okay? Then you have the Paris
Commune.
Leaders from the Paris Commune, they
they they've heard what happened to
Robespierre, so they send a delegation
to the the sections and say, "Hey guys,
we need to defend our hero, okay?" And
so you have this huge crowd moving
towards the National Assembly.
And they're waiting for Robespierre to
appear before them and say, "Fight!
Fight! Fight!"
Okay? Defend the revolution. Save the
revolution. Save Robespierre. They're
waiting for their hero to come out and
lead them.
Robespierre refuses to say a word. He
just He just sits there. Everyone's
begging begging Robespierre, "Please,
Robespierre, we have to do something."
And Robespierre just
he stares off into space, okay?
He's like Jesus at this point. He knows
his fate. He knows his destiny. He
refuses to fight his destiny. He
submits, okay?
Submission.
The soldiers come
and his followers begin into a fight.
Some people die, but a soldier shoots a
pistol into the jaw of Robespierre,
okay? And now he he's covered in blood.
And he's trying to wipe off the blood,
but he's in pain, okay? And
even though he's in pain, they still
take him to the guillotine.
So the passion of Robespierre. He's
being driven on a horse cart with his
followers, and there's about 100 of
them, to the guillotine. They will be
all massacred at once, okay?
And thousands people lining up on the
streets to
to shout, "Down the tyrant! Down the
tyrant!" Okay? They hate Robespierre.
These are people who lost
uh friends, family in the Reign of
Terror. So they want to see this guy
dead.
And ultimately then
Robespierre then is guillotined.
And that's the end of Robespierre.
Okay?
Do you see how these stories line up
perfectly? It is almost as if
Robespierre is trying to act out
the story of Jesus for the French
people. That is his That is his his
intention.
That is his legacy.
He wants people to understand that it
was Jesus who appeared before them, and
Jesus made a ultimate sacrifice because
he loved his people in order to rally
his people to save the revolution and
fight off the enemies of France.
Okay?
These stories line up too well.
Now, we know
that
this story is basically just mythology,
okay?
But, I keep on telling you guys
in history
for us humans, mythology ideas are real.
Okay? So, Robespierre, remember this
mythology or subconsciously knows this
mythology, and he acted out
for the French people in order to
inspire them.
In order to fully realize
the revolution.
Okay?
So,
in other words, the French Revolution
was essentially a religi- religious
mythology
in which Robespierre volunteered
to play the part of Jesus.
Right?
To be Jesus, you need to make the
ultimate sacrifice. You need to
sacrifice yourself in front of people,
and that's what he did.
Okay? And after his death
people now see that he's Jesus
and now people are inspired to believe
that there will be a second coming of
Robespierre.
Someone will come come who will be
Robespierre
and who will lead them to final victory
against all their enemies. And this
person's name is
who?
Who Who comes after Robespierre?
Napoleon.
Did you understand? So, Napoleon takes
advantage
of all this mythology and he uses it in
order to become the king of France,
okay? Robespierre refused to become
king, but Napoleon will become king and
we'll discuss Napoleon
next class.
And this will end our French Revolution
trilogy.
Okay?
All right.
So, right? So, um this is the main
argument, okay? So, I provide basically
this the basic story. But, what's
important for us is now to look at the
evidence.
Okay? So, we're going to look at the
speeches of Robespierre in a context of
French revolutionary history.
All right? To understand his mentality.
Right now, what's really important is
for us to understand his psychology and
ask yourselves, if if
if Robespierre really believed he was
Jesus or a prophet,
then do his speeches, do his words
actually provide evidence for this,
okay? And I will show you that in fact
there is evidence that he does in fact
see himself as a prophet.
But, before I start the evidence,
are you guys clear about this argument?
Are you clear about the story I'm
telling you?
All right?
Are you guys clear?
All right, good. So, let's look at the
evidence.
Sorry.
All right.
Okay, the So, why um Yep. Robespierre's
confident that people will actually
realize that
he's acting as a savior.
That is a great question. Does
Robespierre know that people will will
know? He doesn't, right? He can't know.
And in fact, if you look at the Bible,
the Bible is very clear. Jesus himself
was full of doubt.
He was not completely uh sure
that he people will remember him, okay?
But that's the problem with faith.
If you truly believe in the people, you
will have faith in the people.
You understand? So, it was an act of
faith,
right?
Robespierre never at at any point said,
"Hey,
I am the prophet.
I need to sacrifice myself in order to
save the revolution, okay?" He hints at
that, but he never really says it
outright.
And so, he himself is extremely
conflicted person.
All right? There's a part of him that is
pulling him towards his destiny, but
there's also another part of him that
resists against against this, okay? Do
you understand? We humans are extremely
complicated.
Robespierre was a human being.
Okay?
Okay, does that make sense? He can never
be confident that this will work out in
the end.
But because he took that that leap of
faith, it radically changed human
history. Okay? Because Because Because I
believe, okay, and I will argue this, if
he actually didn't
do this, if he actually just became
king, right? If he seized the crown like
Napoleon did, the French Revolution
would have failed.
And we really wouldn't remember the
French Revolution. And it really
wouldn't change the course of human
history. What I will show you next class
is because he did so, because he
sacrificed himself,
it allowed Napoleon to defeat all of
Europe, okay? Without Robespierre's
sacrifice, Napoleon could not have have
become Napoleon.
All right? So, does that make sense? No
prophet ever truly believes he's the
prophet.
There's always a part of him that is
doubtful, that is skeptical.
Okay? But he persists.
None of and that what makes him heroic,
okay? And this is true for all prophets.
Do that make sense? All right.
French Revolution.
Um Maximilien Robespierre. Okay, so some
basic biographical details about
Robespierre, okay? He was born in a town
called
Arras, which is a province of France,
and his family there
for um few generations was bourgeoisie.
They were all lawyers. His grandfather's
a lawyer, his father was a lawyer.
But, um
his mother, Robespierre's mother, died
giving birth to a younger brother. They
all They both both both died.
Um and then Robespierre's father left
the family and died a few years later in
Belgium or somewhere, okay? So,
Robespierre went from bourgeoisie to
petite bourgeoisie.
His family is still wealthy, but not as
wealthy as before. Uh Robespierre bec-
becomes at a very early age, okay? Maybe
7 or 8. He becomes the man of the
family, okay? He's responsible for
taking care of of his younger brother
and his younger sister.
His grandparents are still pretty
wealthy. They send him to a Jesuit
school, where he excels academically,
okay? His ambition is really to be
Jean-Jacques Rousseau. He wants to be a
philosopher. He wants to be like a poet
philosopher, like Jean-Jacques Rousseau.
He writes a lot. He dreams of a better
world. He's very idealistic. He becomes
a lawyer, and as a lawyer, as I
mentioned, he spends all his time
defending the poor and the weak. He's a
champion of the oppressed.
Um
the Estates-General is um organized, and
he goes and becomes a representative.
And as I said, over the next few years,
he rises to the very top. So, the
question we're looking at today is how
did Robespierre fall?
Okay, so um
as I mentioned,
um before the Estates General is called,
France is in a
is facing economic financial collapse.
And so, King Louis the 16th appoints
Jacques Necker to become the finance
minister. The thing about Necker is that
he understands that, "Listen,
if you people if you want people to to
pay more taxes, you need to give them
more political representation."
Okay? So, Necker becomes a champion of
the middle class, and he's worshipped by
the middle class.
Louis the 16th doesn't really like what
he has to say, and so they have this
back and forth for many years, where
Louis 16th fires him, the people
revolt, Louis 16th hires him back, then
fires him again. Okay? So, this goes on
for quite some time. Necker will also
become
um
Okay.
Around this time, as the Estates General
is being called in order to raise more
taxes from the people,
the Abbé Sieyès, who is who is a
clergyman, he writes a very influential
pamphlet called What Is the Third
Estate? Right? Because the first,
second, and third estates are being
called. The first and second estates
have all the power, the third estate has
no power. So, he writes a very
influential pamphlet
um
asking the question, "What is the Third
Estate?" And the answer and his answer
is, "Everything." Okay? The Third Estate
is everyone in France, 99  99%.
"What has it been until now in the
political order? Nothing. What does it
demand to be? Something." Okay? So,
during this time, pamphlets are like the
internet internet of today. It's how
most people get their news.
And the pamphlets become extremely
um
violent extre- and call for radical
change.
May 5th, 1789, the three estates meet.
King Louis XVI refuses to acknowledge
the third estate. He He refuses to meet
with them. He refuses to heed their
demands. So, what happens is the third
estate form their own national assembly,
okay? And these people are radical.
This is everyone in the middle class,
the bourgeoisie, the petite bourgeoisie,
the sans-culottes. They want more
political power. They want more
political representation in government.
Um while this is happening, people's
mood is becoming more and more radical
and violent.
Okay? So, the people of Paris, they
don't have any bread, they're hungry,
they're unemployed, they feel hopeless,
they feel the king is aloof. So, a group
of people, they storm the Bastille.
The storming of the of the Bastille
happens on July 14th, 1789. This is
important because the national day of
France today is July 14th. Why? Because
on July 14th, the people rose up and
stormed the fortress
of the Bastille in order to get
gunpowder, in order to have their own
army, okay? But not only that, but they
killed the governor of the Bastille and
paraded his head in front of everyone,
okay?
So, people's mood is extremely
violent.
And this violence is happening all
around France. It's been decades of
economic stagnation, poverty, military
defeat. People want a revolution.
Um August 27th, 1789, the National
Assembly declares the
um a new constitution. Okay? This new
constitution is something called the
Declaration of the Rights of Man
and the Citizen. It becomes the basis
for most constitutions in the world.
Okay? This marks the
of a new age in human history.
So, let's look at a a few
passages from the Declaration of Rights
of Man.
For these reasons, the National Assembly
do recognize and declare in the presence
of the Supreme Being, the Supreme Being
is the God of Reason,
and with the hope of his blessing and
favor, the following sacred rights of
man and of citizens. Okay? Do you
understand? These rights were not given
to you by the government, they were
given to you by God.
And these rights can never be taken away
from you, okay?
First, men are born and always continue
free and equal in respect of their
rights. Civil distinctions, therefore,
can be founded only on public utility.
Okay? This is a radical statement.
Everyone is equal in the eyes of God and
therefore in the eyes of the law.
If there's nobility, if there's a
clergy, it's only because we agree
to give them this this distinction based
on their uh utility.
Okay? Based on the fact that they do
public good for us.
All right? So, that's a radical
statement.
Second, the end of all political
associations is the preservation of the
natural and imprescriptible rights of
man. And these rights are liberty,
property, security, and resistance of
oppression.
Okay? These are the fundamental human
rights.
All government, all laws, all society
must be based on these fundamental
principles.
Liberty, property, security, and
oppression.
Uh resistance of of oppression, okay?
Third,
the nation is essentially the source of
all sovereignty,
nor can any individual or any body of
men be entitled to any authority which
is not expressly derived from it.
So, what this is saying is now is now we
have a new god. It's a nation-state.
France becomes the first nation-state.
And all authority derives from the idea
of the nation.
Okay? And no power can supersede the
power of the nation.
Okay?
Does that make sense, guys? Okay, this
is the beginning of modernity, right?
Four, political liberty consists in the
power of doing whatever does not injure
another. You can do whatever you want as
long as you don't harm someone else.
The exercise of the natural rights of
every man has no other limits than those
which are necessary to secure to every
other man the free exercise of the same
right. And these limits are determined
only by the law. Five, the law ought to
prohibit only actions hurtful to
society. What is not prohibited by the
law should not be hindered, nor should
anyone be compelled to that which the
law does not require.
Okay, so this is a new idea of freedom.
Negative freedom, okay? Before it was
positive freedom where you had to do
certain things to become a citizen.
Now, it's like if you're a citizen, you
can you can do whatever you want as long
as you are not hurting someone else and
you're not breaking the law.
And so this is the where the modern our
modern idea of freedom comes from.
All right, six.
The law is an expression of the will of
the community. All citizens have a right
to concur either personally or by their
representatives in its formation. It
should be the same to all whether it
protects or punishes, and all being
equal in its sight are equally eligible
to all honors, places, and employments
according to different abilities without
any other distinction than that created
by their virtues and talents.
Not only is the government now
responsive to the needs
and demands of the people, but the
people can at any time become the
government.
Okay? So, the people are above the the
okay? So, the hierarchy now is
at the very top
is the nation.
And then below the nation
now is the people. Right? And then below
the people now is the government. The
government only exists in order to
protect the rights of the people. So,
the government only exists
at the behest
and
um
concurrence of the people.
All right.
Number 10.
No man ought to be molested on account
of his opinions, not even on account of
his religious opinions, provided his
avowal of them does not disturb the
public order established by law. Okay?
So, this is now the separation of church
and state. You are free to believe
whatever you want.
11. The unrestrained communication of
thoughts and opinions being one of the
most
precious rights of man, every citizen
may speak, write, and publish freely,
provided he is responsible for the abuse
of this liberty in case the government
by law. You are free to say whatever you
want, okay? This is the freedom of
expression.
Okay, so the Declaration of Rights of
Man
basically defines the new liberal order,
okay?
Last is
17. The right to property being
inviolable and sacred, no one ought to
be deprived of it except in case of
evident public necessity legally
ascertained and on condition of a
previous just indemnity, okay? So,
property is also a sacred right.
If you have our property, it is yours by
the will of God.
Obviously, Robespierre does not like
this idea, okay? So, Robespierre gives a
speech
arguing against this idea, and he
proposes an amendment to this idea.
Now, last session, this is Robespierre
speaking before the National Assembly,
okay?
In the last session, I took the floor in
order to make a few important additions
to the Declaration of the rights of man
and of the citizen. It was my intention
to expand your declarations of the
theory of property by the addition of a
few articles. Let the word property
frighten no one.
Filthy souls who value only your money,
I will not violate your treasures, even
though I know how unclean the source
from which they are. From which they
come, okay? So, what he is saying
everyone, I know you guys are rich and
you all want to protect your property.
I won't take away your property. But,
please remember,
every one of you stole this from someone
else. This is how you became rich.
Through theft. Through crimes.
Okay? So, Rousseau has a contempt
for the wealthy.
Ask any one of these traders in human
flesh what is property, okay? How do
people people make money? Through the
slave trade, basically.
He will show you the long coffin called
a ship in which together and chained.
Men who seem yet alive and he will tell
you, "Look at my property. I have bought
it head for head." It It's a known fact
that at this time in history,
a lot people are getting rich off the
slave trade, okay?
Question this noble man who has goods
and subjects and who believes that the
world will can come to an end now that
he no longer possesses
them and he will expound similar ideas
on property to you, okay? Rich people
love their land. They love their wealth.
Question the members of the Capetian
dynasty and they will tell you that the
most sacred property is the right of
inheritance that they have, the ancient
right of oppression, the 25 million
persons now populating the territory of
France
of destroying them, of treating them
legally and morally according to their
own will. Well, so what Rousseau is
saying is that
property cannot be a sacred right
because property requires the oppression
of others.
Right? How do you make your money How do
you How do you make money off land? By
getting people to farm them, right?
You're oppressing people. You're
exploiting people. Therefore, this is a
contradiction.
You're saying
that
property is a sacred right, then you're
saying like God gave people this right.
But God would never give you the power
to oppress others. That makes no sense.
You have increased the number of
articles in order to afford the largest
possible latitude to right to one's
property, and yet you have not added a
word in limitation of this right with
the result that the declaration might
make the impression of having been
created not for the poor, but for the
rich, the speculators, for the stock
exchange jobbers. To remedy this defect,
I propose the following additions. Okay?
So, he's saying at this point in the
revolution, the middle The entire middle
class, including the bourgeoisie, are
participating in this revolution.
But he's also saying that you, the
bourgeoisie,
have written this constitution for your
benefit and not for the benefit of
everyone, for the people.
Okay?
So, we need to make changes. First,
property is that right held by each
citizen to dispose freely of that
portion of the general goods guaranteed
him by the laws.
So, it's society that gives people
property, not God who gives people
property, okay? There's a difference.
Second, the right to property, like all
other rights, is limited by the
obligation to regard the rights of
others.
All right? So, when you speak, you You
can do whatever you want as long as you
don't, you know, harm others.
Well, he What Rousseau is saying is like
that should also apply to property. You
can own property as long as you are
doing so in a way that does not exploit
others.
And the third is
Property may not cause any detriment to
our security or to our liberty or or
existence or to the property of our
neighbor, okay?
Owning property should also not harm the
national interest as well.
So, he's putting severe limitations on
the idea of property because what
Robespierre wants is a society based on
equality of all.
Okay?
Now, um as this revolution is happening,
um
there's a man named Joseph Ignace
Guillotin who will create something
called the guillotine.
Okay? He's a doctor and he wants to
create a more humane way of of executing
people. The guillotine will become the
main mechanism of terror
during the French Revolution, right? So,
if you are an enemy of the state, they
will guillotine you.
Um
as all this happening, the king is
trying to work with the National
Assembly.
But, the king is also conspiring against
the National Assembly by trying to write
to his
family and friends overseas to raise
armies against the revolution.
And,
um
on June 20th to 21st, 1792, the king and
queen actually try to flee France, but
they're recognized and they're captured
and sent back to
uh Paris.
A month later, August 10th, the people
actually storm the king's residence
and um basically massacre
his Swiss Guard, the mercenaries who are
paid to protect him.
Okay?
Finally, they decide to just kill this
guy because he's he's he's threatening
the revolution, okay? King Louis is
always trying to conspire against the
revolution, so they break this taboo,
okay? Because remember, many people many
people believe that the king
is a son of God
and they kill him, okay? And Robespierre
is explaining why and it's very simple,
okay? Louis may die in order that the
revolution may live. It's that simple.
What matters first and foremost is a
revolution.
In order to advance a revolution,
everyone is expendable, including
Robespierre, okay?
Robespierre is only the prophet of
revolution. He is not the revolution it
itself.
Um as this happening,
there's now counter-revolutionaries. So,
in the Vendée, which is in west France,
peasants are rebelling against the
French Revolution. Why? Because French
French Revolution is calling for a
secular state. It's calling for a
negation of religion. And um the thing
about peasants is they love their
religion.
Okay? So, the peasants are now rising up
against the French Revolution, and it is
a brutal war of genocide. Okay, there
are massacres and atrocities on both
sides.
Um on May
uh 31st, Robespierre takes command of
the National Assembly. This is something
called the Montagnard coup because he's
in charge of of a faction called the the
mountain, okay? This is French for
mountain.
And of course, he then begins the Reign
of Terror, okay? We discussed why he
starts the Reign of Terror.
He needs to unite the energies of people
to commit them fully to the revolution,
okay? We can't go back. There's no
coming back after this Reign of Terror.
We have too many enemies now.
Um
the thing about the
um Reign of Terror is he doesn't he
kills his enemies,
but more importantly,
he's also killing his political allies,
okay? The people on the left, he's also
killing as well because they also
threaten the revolution. So, this is
George
uh Danton, and he's one of the leaders
of the Cordeliers, which as as I
mentioned, is a very left-wing
political group calling for the for
universal suffrage, for property rights,
for the sans-culottes.
And he's he's seen as a threat to the
revolution. And like
Robespierre, he's also fanatical. He's a
fanatical prophet. So, the National
Assembly votes to condemn him to death,
and he says, "I have said and I have
shall repeat, my home will soon be in
oblivion and my name in a pantheon. And
here is my head. It will I will it will
answer for everything. My life is a
burden to me. I shall be glad to be rid
of it, okay?" He's like, "Screw you all.
I don't care. I have done God's work."
"If I must rest, I shall rest."
Okay, and then he's guillotined.
Um
Jacques Hébert is the leader of the
Hébertists. He's a journalist, and he's
calling for the complete abolishment of
the Catholic Church. And of course, the
peasants don't like that. The the
peasants would all unite against you.
So, he's seen as a threat to the
revolution, even though he is a close
ally of Robespierre, and Robespierre
also has him killed. Okay? So,
Robespierre is not just killing his
enemies, he's also killing his friends
as well.
And it's all in order to advance the
revolution.
Um
So, now Robespierre needs to explain why
this is happening, okay? And he presents
a vision of the revolution, which tells
us that he sees himself as a prophet.
He's trying to build a new world. It's
Right now, there's a war between good
and evil, and good must triumph, no
matter what the cost.
All right. So, his speech before the
National Assembly to explain the Reign
of Terror.
"To judge by the power and the will of a
Republican soldiers, it will be easy to
defeat the English and the traitors. But
we have another task of no less
importance, but unfortunately of greater
difficulty.
This task is a task of frustrating by an
uninterrupted
access of energy, okay? So, the Reign of
Terror is to energize the people, right?
The eternal intrigues of all enemies of
freedom within the country and of paving
the way for the victory of the
principles on which the general will
depends, okay? So, our true enemies are
not the English, the Austrians, the
Prussians. Our true enemies are those
traders within us. They're the ones who
most threaten
the the revolution.
This is another speech, okay?
What's the goal toward which we are
heading? Why are we doing this?
Why the Reign of Terror?
The peaceful enjoyment of liberty and
equality.
Kingdom of kingdom on Earth. Utopia.
Paradise, okay? A justice and equality.
The ring of of that eternal justice
whose laws
have been inscribed not in marble and
stone, but in the hearts of all men,
even in that of the slave who forgets
them and in that of the tyrant who
denies them.
Okay? This law, this justice, this
equality is what God promised us because
it's implanted in our hearts. We all
yearn for this world when we're all
equal.
When justice prevails. Okay? We are
fighting for the freedom and the
liberation of of all humanity
from oppression. That's why we're
fighting.
We seek an order of things in which all
the base and cruel passions are in
chain. Okay? So, last class we discussed
Jean-Jacques Rousseau. And remember,
Jean-Jacques Rousseau, his most famous
line is
we are born free, but we are all in
chains. Okay? So, this is a rewriting of
that idea.
So, what keeps us in in us in chains are
our emotions.
So, we want a world in which our reason
prevails and we are in control of our
emotions. Then we are truly liberated.
All the beneficent and generous passions
are awakened by the laws. Where ambition
becomes the desire to merit glory and to
serve our country. Okay? So, your
ambition is not to gain wealth at the
expense of others. Your ambition is to
help the community grow and and thrive.
Where distinctions are born only of
equality itself. Where the citizen is
subject to the magistrate,
the magistrate to the people, and the
people to justice.
Where our country assures the well-being
of each individual and where each
individual probably enjoys our country's
prosperity and glory. Where every soul
grows greater through the continual flow
of Republican sentiments and by the need
of deserving the esteem of a great
people. Where the arts are the
adornments adornments of the liberty,
which enables them and commerce, the
source of public wealth rather than
solely the monstrous opulence of a few
families. Guys, he's talking about
communism. Okay? So, I'm going to world
in which everyone is equal.
Everyone is free to do what he or she
wants and this will lead to the general
prosperity, wealth, and happiness of the
entire nation.
Okay?
So, Robespierre is dreaming of a world
in which everyone is equal.
The great purity of the French
Revolution's fundamental elements,
the very sublimity of its objective is
precisely what create our strength and
our weakness.
Our idealism is what gives us power.
Okay? Our strength because it gives us
the victory of truth over deception and
the rights of public interest over
private interest. Our weakness because
it rallies against us all men who are
vicious, all those who in their hearts
plan to despoil the people, and all
those who have despoiled them in what
impunity. And those who reject liberty
as a personal calamity and those who
have embraced the revolution as a
livelihood and the republic as it were
an object of prey. Okay? So, we are
fighting a war of good versus evil.
Among us are men of good
who want to build a better world, who
care for others. But there are also
speculators
among us who use the revolution
who use the revolution in order to
advance
his or her interests.
Okay?
That's why we're fighting this war.
We're trying to rid the world of those
who seek to
exploit others, who prey on others.
Okay? Who enjoy being bad.
That's why we're fighting this war.
Hence the defection of so many ambitious
or greedy men who since the beginning
have abandoned us along the way because
they had not begun the voyage in order
to reach the same goal.
Okay? One could say that the two
contrary geniuses that have been
depicted competing for control of the
realm of nature are fighting in this
great epoch of human history to shape
irrevocably the destiny of the world and
that France is a theater of this mighty
struggle. Okay? This is the end of the
world.
This is the end of the world. This is
good versus evil.
Good must triumph.
It must. So, every sacrifice must be
made.
Without all the tyrants encircle you,
within all the friends of tyranny
conspire. They will conspire until crime
has been robbed of hope. We must smother
the internal and external enemies of the
republic or perish. In this situation,
the first maximum of your policy ought
to be to lead the people by reason and
the people's enemy by terror.
Okay? This reign of terror, it is about
the ultimate victory against evil.
We are killing our enemies because our
enemies destroy
want to destroy all good in the world.
If the mainspring of popular government
in peacetime is virtue, amid revolution,
it is at the same time virtue and
terror. Virtue without which terror is
fatal, terror without which virtue is
impotent. Terror is nothing but prompt,
severe, inflexible justice. It is
therefore an emanation of virtue.
It is less a special principle than a
consequence of a general principle of
democracy applied to our country's most
pressing needs.
We have to be as brutal as our as
enemies
if we are truly to promote democracy.
Okay, there's no there's no other
choice.
All right.
So, the reign of terror is just one
policy that Robespierre adopts in order
to save the revolution. But, he also
adopts a new religion called the
festival the cult of the Supreme Being,
okay? This is a new religion where God
is the god of reason.
All right?
So, Robespierre is adopting a lot of
different policies. And again, he is
working selflessly in order to promote
the revolution.
But, eventually he gets exhausted, okay?
He just breaks down. He has he has he
has a nervous breakdown because it's too
hard.
Like, he wants people to be virtuous. He
wants people to be reasonable. And
everywhere he sees, like he sees
everyone in front of him and everyone's
in everyone's plotting against him.
Everyone's trying to exploit the
revolution for his or her own benefit,
okay? And eventually
Robespierre is brought down and he is
guillotined, okay?
But, let us look at his last speech
to fully understand how he sees the
revolution and his own death. Okay, this
is his last speech before the National
Assembly. This is two days before he is
to be executed. Okay, this is July 26,
1794.
The enemies of the Republic called me
tyrant, okay? The The National Assembly
is now calling for his execution because
he's a tyrant.
Uh were I such, they would grovel at my
feet. I would gorge them with gold. I
should grant them impunity for their
crimes and they would be grateful.
Right? If I'm a tyrant, then I would
make political alliances. I would bribe
people. I would benefit people. But, I
don't do that.
I'm incorruptible. I'm virtuous.
Were I such, the kings we have
vanquished, far from denouncing
Robespierre, would lend me their guilty
support. Okay?
So, the kings of
England,
Netherlands, Austria, Prussia, Russia
are all aligned against
the French Revolution. Why? Because
they're afraid
of revolution at home. Right? So,
Robespierre is saying, "Listen, if I if
I just become a king, they would marry
their daughter to me and we'd all be one
big happy family."
Okay? They would not They would not see
me as a threat.
There would be a covenant between them
and me. Tyranny must have tools. But,
the enemies of tyranny, whether does
their power tend? To the tomb and to
immortality. What tyrant is my
protector? To what faction do I belong?
Yourselves.
Everything I've done is for the people
of France and you know this.
Since the beginning of the revolution
has crushed and annihilated so many
detected traitors. You, the people, our
principles, are that faction. A faction
to which I'm devoted and against which
all the scroundrelism of the day is
banded. Okay? It is because I,
Robespierre, am the am the only virtuous
person who has fought for the
revolution, now do you conspire against
me?
The confirmation of the Republic has
been my object, and I know that the
Republic can be established only on the
internal basis of morality.
Okay? It Only if we are virtuous can we
win out in the end against evil.
Against me, against those who hold
kindred souls, the league is formed. My
life, all my life, I abandon without a
regret. I have seen the past, I foresee
the future. I am the prophet.
I have seen the past, and I foresee the
future.
You will kill me. I accept my fate.
What friend of his country would wish to
survive the moment when he could no
longer serve it, when he could no longer
defend innocence against oppression? You
have taken away my powers? Fine, take
away my life as well, because I serve I
live only to serve.
Wherefore should I continue in an order
of things where intrigue eternally
triumphs over truth, where justice is
mocked, where passion is the most abject
or fears the most absurd override the
sacred interests of humanity?
The pollution has So, the revolution has
been polluted.
It is It is now corrupt.
If it If you take my life, I I'll be
glad to give it to you.
Question history and learn how other
defenders of liberty in all times have
been overwhelmed by calumny, okay? All
prophets in their time were prosecuted,
including Jesus and Socrates.
But their traducers died also. The good
and the bad disappear alike from the
earth, but in very different conditions.
All Frenchmen, all my countrymen, let
not your enemies, with their desolating
doctrines, degrade your souls and
enervate your virtues.
Now is the time to stand up and fight
for the revolution.
I may die, but the revolution must live.
Death is not an eternal sleep. Citizens,
if faced the tomb that model
graven by sacrilegious hands which
breaths over all nature a funeral crepe
takes from oppressed innocence its
support and affronts the beneficent
disposition of death.
Inscribe rather therefore these words,
"Death is the commencement of
immortality. I leave to the oppressors
of the people a terrible instrument
which I proclaim with the independence
befitting one whose career is so nearly
ended. It is the awful truth, thou shalt
die."
Yes, today I die, but so will you.
And when we all die, we must face our
maker.
We must all see God and we must account
for our lives.
I go to God
in full conscious.
I'm happy to go directly to God and
await my fate. Okay, and these are his
last words.
Why should I wish to live under system
where intrigue triumphs over truth,
where justice is a lie, where the basis
passions and the most ridiculous of
terrorists supersede in man's heart the
most sacred duties? Why should I regret
to escape from the eternal torture of
seeing this horrible session of traders
who by concealing the turpitude of their
souls under the veil of virtue and even
of friendship will leave prosperity in
doubt which was the greater, the
cowardice or their crimes?
You
members of the National Assembly were
elected to serve the people.
You have only served yourself. You have
only fought for your own economic
interest.
And because you see me as a threat, you
see Robespierre as a man of purity, of
virtue, of reason, you conspire against
me. And I am happy
to be condemned to death because it will
it will
liberate me from this evil world that
you have created. But upon my death,
there shall come vengeance.
Okay?
So, that's it, guys.
That's Robespierre.
All right. So,
Does Does this make sense?
Okay? He sees himself as a prophet who
must save the revolution.
At first, he believes that he must kill
his enemies,
the enemies of the revolution, in order
to save the revolution. But then he
recognizes that No, no, no.
This reign of terror isn't really about
energizing people. It's really about
eliminating
the enemies
of his allies.
Okay? It's really about political
intrigue.
And so, he recognizes that
if this revolution is to really triumph,
then he must make the ultimate
sacrifice.
Rather than
try to seize the crown, he must give his
life for the revolution to set an
example for everyone, especially the
oppressed and the weak.
And after he dies,
this will energize France. It will unite
France.
It becomes a hurricane. Okay? The French
Revolution now becomes a hurricane. All
right? And Napoleon will come, he will
take this hurricane, and he will unleash
it on the entire world, and he will
conquer the entire world. And that's
what we'll do the next class. Okay?
We'll look at Napoleon.
But does this make sense to you guys?
Any questions?
Yeah, go.
Okay.
Okay. So,
um
the question is
are people conscious of what Roast Beef
is doing?
And I I know this is a hard argument, um
and I I I know this is hard to
understand, but this is all happening
subconsciously.
Okay? This is all happening without
people being aware uh of it. Roast Beef
is not aware of it, the people are not
aware of it. Okay? So, the argument goes
like this.
First of all,
mythology
is the collective subconscious.
Okay? Mythology is the collective
subconscious. That That's the first
idea. Okay? Does that make sense to you?
Okay. Second idea is this.
When authority
breaks down,
the mythology
takes over.
Okay, do you understand? Okay? The ar-
argument is this. Usually, someone in
authority
orders people around, right? Someone in
authority, whether it's a general or
a priest or a teacher,
tells you what to do.
But when you deny this authority, when
you reject this authority,
what tells you what to do? Well,
mythology, okay? Your collective
subconscious.
Okay? You're guided by your collective
subconscious, even though you don't know
it.
Okay?
The third argument is that
mythology
is essentially a play.
Okay? A mythology is a play. It's a
story.
And
this play requires actors.
Okay? So,
the leaders
become now the actors.
This play must take place because that's
what people want.
Now you need actors. You need volunteers
to come and be the actors in this play.
So, whoever
whoever volunteers now must play that
role,
and then people will follow that person.
Okay? So, Robespierre
played the role role of Jesus, so people
followed him. Even though people don't
really know why they're following him,
okay? Does that make sense? But they're
following him because he's willing to
play the role
that's required of him in this play
that's being acted out during the French
Revolution.
Okay?
But, and this is really important,
this play only works
if people play the role they're supposed
to play. When they speak the lines
they're supposed to speak, right?
That's really important.
Because what happens is if people break
the role, and instead of people listen,
I was just acting, the entire play dies.
Okay? The play dies. Why is this
important? Because
next class, we will look at Napoleon.
Okay? In the beginning, Napoleon is
playing his role.
Right? He's the Messiah come to Earth to
lead the French people to final victory
against evil,
to unite the world in good. He's playing
that role.
But then he does something
that he should not do,
and which breaks the play, and which is
what?
Do you guys Do you guys know?
What does Napoleon do that Robespierre
doesn't do?
That's right. He He calls himself
emperor. You're not supposed to do that.
Okay?
If you're a Robespierre, you would never
declare yourself emperor. You're going
to make yourself first citizen, you're
going to make yourself consul, dictator,
whatever, but you cannot make yourself
emperor because now you're like everyone
else.
Right? And when he does that, and this
is very important, he destroys the
French Revolution.
And after that, France
is now destroyed by their enemies.
Napoleon falls.
Okay?
Does that make sense, guys?
So, only if
you
are
playing your role can this play work
out. Once this play works out, people
are energized to sacrifice their lives.
Okay? The reason why Napoleon at first
could defeat all his enemies is his
soldiers were not afraid to die. Okay?
They didn't care. They're like, "Well,
you know, if we die, we're going to
heaven." That's what Robespierre did.
Okay, but we'll discuss this next class.
Okay?
Does that make sense?
So, it's a hard argument to make because
like I'm I'm arguing like there is a
subconscious
operating system to society that we
don't ever see.
Okay? That we don't we we don't ever
talk about. But once we see this, okay,
then it helps us explain the world we
live in.
It explains a lot of history to us.
But you need to be able to see it first.
And most people don't see it, okay? If
you look at
the traditional accounts of the French
Revolution, it's always these economic,
political, structural forces, okay?
I'm presenting a different idea here.
Okay? Does that make sense?
Great. Any Any Any other questions?
Um so, like you mentioned that like
Reign of Terror is a
a kind of um
human sacrifice? Yep. And it is a like
uh
a way to replicate Jesus?
No. No. Um the Reign of Terror was a
form of human sacrifice, okay? They
literally took their enemies and they
killed them in front of everyone, right?
And that's no different from the Aztecs,
no different from the Vikings, no
different from the Romans, okay? These
are all societies that practice human
sacrifice in order to unite the people,
right? To galvanize the people, energize
them, create blood lust,
to terrorize their enemies,
and to break taboo, to tell
to send a message that we will never go
back.
We are going towards total victory.
We won't surrender. We won't compromise,
okay? That has nothing to do with Jesus.
In fact, Jesus
The story of Jesus is to tell us
we no longer need human sacrifice
because Jesus made the ultimate
sacrifice, okay?
Does that make sense?
Okay? But
um
but
the Reign of Terror, what it did was
unleash all this energy,
okay? And this energy, it's polluted
energy because it's it's it's it's based
on violence, on vengeance, on hatred,
right? So, what Robespierre decides to
do, and it's very clever of him, he he
needs to now to purify this energy,
right? And how do you purify this
energy? By becoming a scapegoat, by
sacrificing yourself,
by telling the French people the Reign
of Reign of Terror was not your fault.
It was my fault. Blame me.
Sacrifice me
okay?
for what happened. I will take the guilt
for the nation.
I will cleanse cleanse you of your sins
so that you may move on.
Okay? Does that Does Does that make
sense?
Okay? Good.
Any more questions?
Great questions, guys.
Okay. All right. So,
this ends part two of the French
Revolution. Next class on Tuesday is
Napoleon. And this will end the French
Revolution trilogy.
Okay?